The military helicopter sailed through the
skies at a steady pace, its destination somewhere
in Southwest Asia, along one of the many points
where the legendary Euphrates and Tigris rivers
meet.
Depending on the outcome, this mission may
have changed the course of the SCP Foundation
and its activities forever, or it might do
nothing at all.
Such was often the way when it came to dealing
with the unpredictable and the anomalous.
Inside the helicopter, Dr. Anton Zharkov was
practically rattling with nervous excitement.
Ever since he’d been assigned to the 682
Termination Detail, after years of wasting
away in an archival desk job, he’d seen
the kind of anomalies you wouldn’t believe.
173, that nightmarish statue that snaps the
necks of anyone who dared to look away from
it.
811, the strange and also strangely adorable
Swamp Woman, whose caustic mucus could reliably
melt seemingly any organic matter - save,
of course, 682 itself.
And Dr. Zharkov was particularly astonished
by the aftermath of the epic battle between
096 and 682 , which left both of these “indestructible”
monsters horribly maimed.
But all of that...
It was nothing compared to what they were
going to witness today.
Dr. Zharkov muttered a prayer to himself in
frightened reverence.
Dr. Clef, who was sitting across from him
in the helicopter, wasn’t quite as wound
up.
Like some action movie cliche made manifest,
he sliced chunks from a plump, red apple with
a Bowie knife and sucked the pieces off the
blade.
Clef found Zharkov’s nervousness little
more than amusing.
“First time at Site 0, rookie?”
Clef asked between apple slices.
Dr. Zharkov nodded, forcing a meek smile.
Clef just chuckled.
“You’re wasting your time, you know,”
Clef said.
“Everyone takes a shot at the reptile.
I faced it down myself once, mano e mano,
and during that moment, I realized something.
As much as it pains me to ever throw in the
towel, we’re not gonna kill this thing.
It’s just a budget sink.”
Of course, these kinds of doubts had crossed
Dr. Zharkov’s mind before.
He’d watched countless termination attempts,
organized by far more senior researchers than
himself, fail and fail embarrassingly.
Something about signing your name up for 682
termination was like tying on a blindfold,
grabbing a bat, and stepping up to a piñata,
except in this case, the piñata isn’t wearing
a blindfold, and somehow it can hit you back.
It’s a one-way ticket to professional humiliation,
and if you’re unlucky enough to get too
close when things go south, it can be so much
worse.
But Dr. Zharkov well and truly believed that
he would be the exception to so much miserable
failure.
After all, this was an idea nobody had tried
before...
An announcement over the intercom signaled
that they had now entered Site 0 airspace.
They’d be landing shortly.
And just like that, Dr. Zharkov was all raised
hairs and gooseflesh once again.
It seemed like such a hazy, distant miracle
that his project proposal would even get majority
approval from the O5 Council.
And now, he was about to touch down and actually
see it.
Naturally, Dr. Clef noticed Dr. Zharkov’s
emotional cues, and like so many playground
bullies, decided to seize on it.
“Don’t buy into the hype,” Dr. Clef
said.
“It’s really not that special.”
The helicopter touched down.
Dr. Zharkov felt defensive, he was almost
tempted to use hard words, but he realized
from Dr. Clef’s mischievous smile that perhaps
that was always the intention.
He certainly had a...
Reputation, if one were to put it in the most
neutral terms possible.
“But this was your 001 proposal, Dr. Clef,”
Zharkov countered.
“I would have thought you’d be more invested
in this.”
Dr. Clef rose to his feet and sheathed his
Bowie knife as the helicopter’s side door
opened.
He gestured for Dr. Zharkov to get up and
follow him, before saying, “Believe me,
even a giant flaming Demi-God loses its luster
when you need to write enough of those stupid
reports on it.”
The two researchers disembarked from the helicopter
and walked into the legendary containment
facility: Site 0.
One of the most important and secretive containment
sites out there, even by the standards of
the ever-clandestine SCP Foundation.
If ever containment procedures failed here,
they’d be staring down the barrel of an
unprecedented situation: A PATMOS XK-Class
End of the World Scenario.
After all, they were dealing with one of the
most serious and powerful anomalies they’d
ever contained here.
Clef and Zharkov entered the control room,
filled with huge monitors displaying every
kind of recordable metric, but the largest
screens were dominated by long-range drone
footage of the iconic anomaly they were all
there to see: SCP-001, perhaps better known
as Uriel, The Gate Guardian.
While Dr. Clef remained unfazed, Dr. Zharkov
felt a single tear crawling down his cheek.
He had never seen an entity so utterly awe-inspiring.
An impossibly tall, glowing humanoid entity
with eight great, fiery wings, and a glowing
blade made of pure heavenly fire, every bit
as hot as the sun.
To think that such an incredible creature
existed on the same earth as him made him
feel so incredibly small.
The theories as to the creature’s true nature
were as myriad as they were unknowable.
Some of the more devout among the Foundation’s
ranks even believe that he is a direct servant
of the Abrahamic God, guarding the gate the
paradise, the Garden of Eden, Heaven itself.
Dr. Clef just laughed.
“Everything you hoped it’d be, Zharkov?”
he said.
Dr. Zharkov nodded.
“And more, Dr. Clef, and more.”
Even from such a distance, the raw power of
the Gate Guardian is impossible to ignore.
It radiates off of the being like an invisible
aura.
Dr. Zharkov had read all the files, to get
within a kilometer of the mighty entity would
be to court death.
Anyone who approached it would taste the heat
of its sword, cleaving them apart at the atomic
level and effectively erasing them from existence.
It’s about as dead as anyone could possibly
be - Save for someone being thrown into SCP-3930
and literally removed from the plane of existence.
SCP-3930 had failed to annihilate the Hard
to Destroy Reptile.
But perhaps where that whole lot of nothing
had failed, the Gate Guardian would succeed.
It remained floating, fixed on one place,
as though waiting for…
Something.
But what?
Perhaps a fateful confrontation with a certain
reptilian nightmare, Dr. Zharkov hoped.
Like many, he had heard the most famous story
involving SCP-001: The Gate Guardian, which
took place before even the days of the SCP
Foundation.
After all, every Foundation needs a Founder,
doesn’t it?
And that’s how it began.
The Founder was a mysterious figure, no matter
who you ask.
Some say it was O5-1, others say it was the
legendary Administrator.
Some even believe that it was someone else,
someone older, someone who predated even the
current O5 Council and Administrator.
A wise and learned figure, going on a pilgrimage
around the known world in hopes of expanding
their perspective and seeking out the strange
and unusual.
It was traveling down the River Tigris that
the Founder encountered the Gate Guardian
- Of course, as always, from a mile away.
The Founder saw the distant glowing point
shaped like a human being with wings.
It was unlike anything they’d ever borne
witness to.
That’s when the Founder felt a door open
in the back of their mind, and something sneak
in.
A single word, projecting somehow infinite
authority.
“PREPARE.”
The very presence of the word made the Founder’s
body rattle.
Never had they heard such a voice, conveying
such certainty and power.
It had to be the voice of the distant glowing
figure, it couldn’t be anything else, could
it?
Much like Dr. Zharkov would experience hundreds
of years later, the Founder, even as a person
so powerful, knowledgeable, and influential,
suddenly felt so unimaginably small.
The Founder became aware of not just the extent
of the world around them, or even the universe,
but a terrifying multiverse of possibilities.
There was light out there, of course, but
even more darkness.
And terrifying things were hiding in the dark.
Is that what “prepare” meant?
Did it mean to be ready for all the terrible
things hiding in the dark, just waiting for
the opportunity to strike?
Just how great was the extent of the things
humanity didn’t understand out there?
The Founder’s mind was flooded with so many
possibilities - If there was a tide of monsters
in the blackness that needed to be fought
back, it was too much for any one person to
ever handle.
The Founder needed a group, all gathered around
the same mission: To contain the coming threat
that the great glowing being had warned them
about.
People of focus, commitment, and sheer willpower.
People who would accept the knowledge of the
terrible things in the darkness and still
not waver in the face of their great and noble
challenge.
People who, if necessary, would be willing
to die in the dark so the rest of the human
race would live in the light.
They would be humanity’s greatest defenders,
even though they would defend in secret.
This was how it had all begun, supposedly.
Dr. Zharkov had heard the story whispered
many times while conducting his research into
SCP-001.
And now, here he stood, perhaps where the
Founder had been standing all those years
ago.
The SCP Foundation had faced down greater
threats than SCP-682 - The Hanged King, The
Sealed King, The Scarlet King, hell, if they
wanted to, they could go toe to toe with the
Burger King.
And all of it had begun with a single word
from the mighty Gate Guardian.
Surely an ornery, overgrown lizard wouldn’t
be too much for it to handle?
But of course, they hadn’t just come here
to look at the Gate Guardian, that’d be
an egregious waste of time and helicopter
fuel.
They’d come here transporting precious cargo:
A chunk of SCP-682’s flesh, cut from the
beast itself.
Currently, it was attached to yet another
remote-controlled drone, set on a collision
course for the Gate Guardian.
Dr. Zharkov watched the video feeds with sweaty
palms as he saw the drone and its diabolical
cargo enter the video’s view, getting closer
to the Gate Guardian by the moment.
Closer, closer, closer.
Until…
The Gate Guardian struck out with its great
and terrible sword.
For such an astronomically huge being to move
so incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself, but what Dr. Zharkov found even more
exciting was the result: In one quick slash
of its solar blade, both the drone and the
SCP-682 tissue sample were utterly evaporated.
Gone, reduced to less than even ash.
Dr. Zharkov’s face split into a manic grin.
If it could destroy the tissue sample, then
surely, it could destroy the monster itself,
and what a glorious day that would be…
Meanwhile, back at the cross-testing chambers
of Site-19, SCP-682 was having another miserable
day.
It was dragged, half-melted, out of its acid
tank at 3 AM in the morning and left slowly
regenerating on the floor.
A typical SCP Foundation wake-up call, it
thought to itself with a roll of its still-regenerating
eyes.
What form of horrible torment would be in
store for it this time?
It began scrolling through its mental Rolodex
for the most recent failed-but-painful termination
attempts.
Oh, yes, of course, they’d tried suffocation
via vacuum!
That definitely made SCP-682 feel a little
light-headed, at least.
Until, of course, it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition to
its native atmosphere, which had certainly
given those white-coat-wearing sadists a lot
to take notes about.
Then, how could it forget, they’d tried
roasting it to death with extremely high temperatures.
Thankfully, as always, it’d had a trick
up its sleeve: Adapting a carapace made of
solid helium to defend it from the fire, then
shattering it to shred a bunch of those buffoons
in the orange jumpsuits.
Then they’d cut off a sample of its flesh
shoved it into some absurd industrial blender
before shoving what’s left into a centrifuge.
What a divine pleasure it had been for 682
to hear the explosion down the hall, when
the antimatter embedded in its jeans went
off and put a number of those idiotic Foundation
drones in the hospital for months.
Serves them right for continually meddling
in the matters of forces they couldn’t even
hope to understand.
And today…
They were feeding it the carcass of a dead
cow.
SCP-682 sighed.
It felt sometimes that the dolts testing it
had forgotten the note reading “Highly Intelligent”
on its file.
Being dragged into one of these ghastly chambers
and given some form of novel stimulus could
only mean one thing: Something stupid and
painful was going to happen.
Said stupid, painful thing, in this case,
was that the cow was spiked with an instance
of SCP-3521 - also known as The Banana Pill,
by dado.
What followed was a remarkably absurd instance,
even by SCP-682 cross-test standards, where
a huge number of bananas spontaneously burst
out of 682’s body.
Being a big fan of bananas, apparently, 682
was actually able to eat and metabolize the
bananas faster than the anomalous Banana Pill
- by dado - could produce them.
And because bananas are each, individually,
slightly radioactive, 682 was able to synthesize
this collective radiation into a powerful
death ray that it used to cause a great deal
of death and destruction.
As far as Dr. Zharkov, and the rest of the
SCP Foundation, were concerned, this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level by
the Gate Guardian couldn’t come soon enough.
Sometimes, it took the ultimate knight to
slay the ultimate dragon.
Not long after that, SCP-682 was dosed up
on enough sedatives to give New York City
a week-long nap, and carted over to Site 0
on a heavily secured armored convoy.
Taking SCP-682 this far between containment
sites was considered a matter of grave seriousness.
In other words, the results of this little
experiment better have been good to justify
the insane security risk it took to even get
the damn lizard out here.
Dr. Zharkov and Dr. Clef decided to co-supervise
the cross test, from the safety of the Site
0 observation deck.
Either would have to be beyond foolish to
want to get any closer - Even Dr. Clef, while
undeniably a loose cannon, didn’t have an
outright death wish.
Unless, of course, wishing death on SCP-682
would count.
682’s sedated body was strapped to a large,
unmanned vehicle - the kind they might use
for an exploratory mission on another planet
- and sent in the direction of the Gate Guardian’s
deadly proximal zone.
A secondary camera drone was also sent in
to lag behind, correctly predicting that,
when the Gate Guardian struck SCP-682, it
would obliterate the unmanned vehicle, too.
And whatever happened out there, the Foundation
needed it on camera.
Dr. Zharkov had sweaty palms and gritted teeth,
seeing the culmination of his professional
career unfold in front of him.
Dr. Clef was looking at a meme on his phone.
As 682 got closer, it began hearing a booming
voice in its head, just like the Founder had
so long ago.
The voice simply said one word, over and over,
getting louder as the unmanned vehicle brought
the two titans closer and closer and closer.
“DIE.”
682, still feeling groggy, thought, “Oh,
if it onlywere so simple…”
And then it happened: SCP-682 entered the
dreaded one-kilometer range.
The Guardian slashed down with its mighty
sword, creating a brilliant flash of light.
In the aftermath, the unmanned vehicle was
obliterated, and 682 was left heavily injured
on the ground, still trying to process what
had just happened.
682 looked up, sobered by the pain, and saw
the being that had dealt this blow.
682 began to sneer.
“Is this meant to be the Garden?”
it said, before breaking into a venomous laugh.
“This is not the Garden.
The Garden is far west of here.”
The Gate Guardian struck again with its flaming
blade, once again projecting that single word,
“DIE, DIE, DIE, DIE, DIE…”
When the smoke cleared, 682 was even more
horrifically injured, with only one limb left,
but still, against all odds, alive.
It used the one limb to drag itself towards
the Gate Guardian, fueled by pure rage and
spite.
“Die?
You command me to die?
Oh, wouldn't we all like that, but this is
my curse for suggesting the fruit,” the
reptile growled.
Back at the base, Dr. Zharkov was mortified.
How could it possibly be surviving all this?
The sword was meant to cleave apart its victims
on an atomic level!
Atomic!
As in, freaking atoms, god damn it!
Dr. Zharkov wished he had a paper bag to breathe
into.
Dr. Clef, showing an uncharacteristic degree
of compassion, patted Zharkov on the back,
saying, “It’s okay, buddy, we all remember
our first time.”
Back at the center of the action, the Gate
Guardian blasted the 682 with its solar blade
again.
Somehow, despite the terrifying power wielded
by the Guardian, 682 continued to live.
It was alive, barely, but after three strikes
from the sword, to be alive was whatever the
evil version of a miracle would be.
“This is not the Garden, and you are not
Uriel,” 682 roared, before spitting at the
Gate Guardian.
“Pretender.”
One more violent strike from the Gate Guardian
and 682 finally collapsed, unconscious from
the extent of its pain and its injuries.
But despite all of Dr. Zharkov’s hopes,
the Gate Guardian did not strike a killing
blow on the unconscious beast.
Instead, it transmitted another word, another
order, impossible for any human being to ignore.
“REMOVE.”
As though in a trance, the workers of Site
0 - including Dr. Zharkov and Dr. Clef - entered
the forbidden one-kilometer exclusion zone.
The Gate Guardian allowed them safe passage,
as they used tools and vehicles to pick up
the heavily injured SCP-682 and cart it away
from the Gate Guardian’s feet.
After they all came back to their senses,
Dr. Zharkov simply said, “What just happened?”
Dr. Clef just shrugged.
“I’ve learned to stop questioning it.”
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Way The
World Ends - The Gate Opens” and “SCP-682
- Ways SCP Foundation Tried to Kill Hard To
Destroy Reptile” for more madness from the
two combatants featured in today’s epic
video!